yeah so what do you make of what's
happened on the markets in the last few
days well it's been an extraordinary
period of instability stemming directly
from the Chancellor's announcements on
Friday and it started of course with a
drop in the value of the pound it then
spread to Banks and building societies
we're trying hundreds of mortgage
products it's placed extreme pressure on
the bank of England to raise interest
rates and hence mortgage rates more than
they were planning and yesterday we had
a situation where a number of major
Pension funds were in danger of going
off the cliff so this has been an
extraordinary
Rippling consequence of financial
instability as a direct result of what
the government announced last Friday and
the government would say the UK is not
alone in suffering many of the pressures
that we're under at the moment they say
that other countries are experiencing
extraordinary levels of inflation
concerns about energy prices and also to
suffering their currency suffering
against a very strong dollar as well and
they say that they have a plan for
growth that is one that will help people
in the long term with a global context
was precisely the reason why this
shouldn't have been done it's true that
this was done at a time when inflation
was already high when there was some
pressure in the bank to increase rates
that was precisely what compounded the
mistake of Last Friday I mean we said
last Friday that doing this at this
moment and it's running a huge risk with
the public finances so the global
context is not a reason for the current
Financial instability we've seen since
Friday the global context meant they
shouldn't have announced the package
which led to it you say that it runs a
risk with the public finances but labor
likes quite a lot of their plan don't
they you're keeping the cut to income
tax the basic rate you've got to look at
this in around rather than through the
lens of individual measures if you think
about what's happened in recent years we
had to borrow a lot of money through
covert as a country the bank their
markets understood that they didn't
overreact to that other countries did it
to similarly with Energy prices where we
called for an energy price freeze other
countries are doing similar things to
protect consumers right now again
markets have not overreacted to those
things the thing that really triggered
this was a whole series of unfunded tax
cuts compounded compounded by the
chancellor then seeing at the weekend
this was only the beginning well he was
right that it was only the beginning but
not in the way that he meant but you
want to take on one of those unfunded
tax cuts how are you going to pay for it
the cost of that that tax got the 19p
the cut to 19p for example that um the
cost of bringing that forward for a year
is a fixed cost of 5 billion because it
was already planned for the following
year so that in itself is not enormous
what's happened here is you have to take
the package in the round and the in the
round effect of it has been to lead to
the financial instability in recent days
and even worse has actually called into
question the economic credibility of the
country it's an act of colossal
irresponsibility precisely because it
was done at a time when those other
pressures which you mentioned were there
and yet labor is also promising other
spending at a time of huge pressures on
public finances you've announced that
every primary school children in England
would have access to fully funded
breakfast clubs for example if labor got
into Power have you got a fully costed
plan for that yeah we do I mean one of
the most egregious things it was
announced last Friday was to get rid of
the 45p rate of income tax for people
earning over 150 000 pounds a year I
mean any effect
support the government announced was
that they would borrow from my
constituents in Wolverhampton in order
to fund a tax cut for people earning
over 150 000 pounds a year so we've said
we would not go ahead with that and by
keeping that in place that raises enough
money to pay for the measure that you've
just announced or you've just mentioned
what do you want to see the government
do now I think they need to revisit this
whole package we've had a lot of talk
from ministers today about we're going
to stay the course uh we're not going to
change course we're going to stick with
it that kind of rhetoric what's more
important here is not saving face for
the prime minister or the chancellor
it's saving people's mortgages saving
their livelihoods this has caused huge
instability it is a classic example of
ideology over economics and this is not
a game they are playing with the
livelihoods of people so they need to
pause and reconsider the evidence from
the obr needs to be published on what
the impact of this would be and they
need to stop playing ideal ideological
games and restore credibility for the
country and financial stability in the
markets